New York City New York the boys are
coming to the great white way on
Broadway at the Town Hall theater May
9th standup comedy Kippy and I co-
headline then we play the little a with
the crowd it's the biggest show we've
ever done we want to sell it out come
out and see us yeah get your tickets at
R garbage.com where the ru garbage card
game is available right now for sale
it's it's over 50 of our favorite
questions from the show some you have
heard some you haven't heard it's a good
time get it play with your friends find
out who's trash yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that a little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
if they grew it to be classy yeah or
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash trash
I'm your host a Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toties in the new edition she just got
word accepted Temple University there
you go she's taking some classes next
semester probably selling weed trying
out for the basketball team I think
that's more of a social move sure my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
an international businessman the gummy
bear bandit himself give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan harb brro send this kid
some money will you what up thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate youw subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are true to R cooking then
obviously the greatest website of all
time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you go
over there you get all your bonus
content baby it's a goddamn party and
check out rug garbage.com grab some
tickets for Town Hall Town Hall here in
New York City mhm May 9th sounds about
right yeah and pick up those areu
garbage card games that are going around
there flying off the shelves those fly
shelves grab them before they're gone
gang and how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he crosses the te's and he dos the
eyes give it up for T-Bone MC scuffins
Toby McMullen everybody there you go
what up boys I'm stoked I love this dude
we have in talk about like breakout
comedian of last year my f my new
favorite guy I'm not a fan but you know
whatever that's just me I like when
T-Bone's excited it's like the dog
running around the house like that zies
it's only for Jay and skateboarders he
gets excited it's you and Tony Hulk so
you're in good company dude that's great
being the in the same league as Tony I
love that well let's not be
crazy we have to give him his peanut
butter balll and put him in the corner
for a little while get him his lick
pad gang the long hair ain't lying we
could be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today he's a
goddamn fan favorite like the long hair
said he is a [__] International
sensation and he's going to be at the
wilbour Boston January 12th make sure
you pick up some ticks for that it's
coming up real quick and he's going to
be at the Vogue theater in Vancouver
British Columbia on February 24th give
it up for the one the only Chay Dana
everybody there he is there he is the
kid dog how is everyone doing today
always always get me on the Instagram
with the videos something pops up I'm
about to see a butthole and your head
Pops I love it I love it when I get
someone caught in that when they're like
they're they they're you're they're
getting involved they're like who is
this baddy and then I'm like what are
you doing do I know your face is going
topr 4th in Cincinnati come see me godam
it oh man you just been chaed yeah dude
that's like when someone texts you when
you're doing your business on your phone
your little text Pops down God damn it
I've had that with you where you've been
fighting with me and I'm like shut
up like what the [__] dude I'm like a
give me 90 seconds that's like like
you're like you're like mid-stroke
you're getting it going an important
call comes in you got to be like hello
this is Chay
Rena are the results
in it's on Zoom they're like you still
got the dog collar on you want to take
that off for us dude I love to like man
I I wish there would be a way where I
could still have the Wi-Fi coming
through but silence all the calls
because I'm I'm a phone jerker I don't
know if you guys are like if you're
jerking off on a computer you're nuts
crazy you're in the CIA or something
desktop desk two screens going you're
like like counting Daddy it's like
Minority Report with all this [__]
throwing
[__] but holes butth holes no I like I
really like to indulge when I get like
multiple tabs open I got nothing going
on my thing if I'm really [__] being
a slob you go multi- tabs on your phone
oh yeah you're jumping tabs on your
phone really I I don't start watching
the video this is like my ritual is I'll
open x videos I'm an x videos guy that's
my go-to porn website you hear that
folks I I'll start scrolling the main
feed I see a video I like open a new tab
go back to the main feed keep scrolling
scrolling stockpiling stock pile how
long's the stockpile sesh last for you
what are you sitting there having a
glass of wine you [__] weirdo get
your business done and get out of there
it's a goddamn Bank job you don't hang
around I jerk off the thumbnails more
than anything else that is what it's
getting itchy trigger
finger God damn I I I always I got to go
to the bottom of the page if I don't go
to the bottom of the page I feel like I
almost get like I'm missing something
like I'm like I missed out there might
have been that perfect jerk you need a
hobby dude make up Checkers or something
do some push-ups or something you said
you were doing the breathing exercises
oh yeah I'm big on the whm Hoff
breathing I like to do that I was
telling you guys this before before I go
on stage mro man myself but whatever
whatever you choose I'll do the Wim Hoff
hyperventilation breathing before you on
stage I've been doing that for a long
time cuz it gets you really focused now
I started putting a Zin in and then do
the Wim Hoff at the same time so I get
this like nicotine boost and those
breathing thing I'm having the sets of
my life I'm
feeling this dude's boofing
skull I tried that once I tried to Str
like I was like real hung over and like
I remember I stretched my quads out
before I went up and I bombed so bad and
I was like never again am I physically
prepping for a set no no no you go on
rough and then you that's the you get
warm as you go this thing gets better
yeah warm up I did that I used to Sprint
back and forth in the like outside for a
little bit where like run up the block
and run back just to get my heart like
you were mugging
somebody I mean you were 40 when you
started comedy just 40-year-old man and
some other guy's clothes running down 17
Street sprinting at you just women
screaming oh my God they're cowering my
baby shut up lady I got I got an open
mic I got to get to I'm up next they
called my name yeah dude he's sprinting
through just knocking people over I got
10 I've got 10 this police dog hot on my
trail that's my biggest fear man a
police dog oh [__] that dude yeah are
not gentle just [__] stab me or
something
whatever yeah hit me with the Tas dude
don't send the German Shepherd after me
apparently they're not allowed to shoot
you in the leg like to like slow you
down they got they go to use like taser
mace something shooting you in the leg
is like uh a cruel and unusual
punishment or some [__] like that that's
also [__] in the movies man you [__]
You're Gonna Miss oh true you know what
I mean you somebody moveing that legs
are tough to hit they are yeah I'd be
really squirly with those too [__]
dancing doing the Irish jig baby doing
this
thing sir he's doing the robot can't get
a lock on him doing the worm down the
street you'll never get me
copper uh there's that all time one of
the dudes getting tased and uh he's like
fighting with his wife or something or
somebody and he gets tased and as he's
getting tased like I'm going to [__] you
up point to whoever he's fighting with
then he lays down like God damn that
guy's coming back for vengeance for sure
wait just fck you're going to get
yours what else is cooking brother oh
what else is cooking right now uh I mean
we I've been having like a I'm pretty
keeping it pretty lowkey right now I've
been trying to cut out the booze trying
to do the dry January I'm trying to cut
the porn for January too cuz I started
getting deep in the porn too much just
like six tabs only yeah he's on page
987 one more page and just F I'm trying
to focus on getting back in like good
good shape I'm sry I'm starting to CU
you're an in shaped gentleman but I used
to be like I used to look good dude I
used to look good so I want to get back
to that focusing like you know doubling
down on standup I want to get into some
of the bigger clubs in New York this
year too so I'm like I'm I'm in a lot of
the beat clubs very driven very game
game plan oriented calculated in a good
way yes career is has always been like
the big driver for me that is like focus
on that put your energy into that and
then all the pieces kind of come around
that and everything else works good so
that everything I'm doing this year is
very career oriented per usual yeah I
want this guy to be my mentor Jesus
Christ my life coach he's good good kid
we kind of fell into this and then
really started
drinking I do miss the booze a bit like
I like a good booze hang with the boys
when you oh you just [__] throw a
couple I'm a big UFC guy so like the
fights are on like you go um there's a
[__] meme with Shane Gillis you know
that that it's like oh you're going to
take me to Buffalo Wild Wings to watch
all the prelims and all the fights and
it's that Shane Gillis thing where he
goes you trying to make me come dude you
brought me down here to make me
come I love that [__] it's so good shout
out to the young what's a cocktail what
you're out drinking what are you what
are you getting o I'm not a beard are
you a bar are you a dive bar guy you a
Swanky Club guy what what are you doing
there dive all the time I love a dive
where it's like [__] all over the walls
weird weird stickers and [__] bathroom
smells like piss that is like that's a
go too for me uh and I'm I'll I'll
usually like my standard is a tequila
soda that'll I can drink those all night
um but if I'm out on a date I and
there's like a cocktail list that has
like seven eight cocktails I be like
let's
[__] I like that yeah and then we'll
just start working through it I had a I
went to Greece recently went to Greece
and I had the best cocktail I've ever
had in my [__] life dude this guy
made uh an oldfashioned that was like
sweet and they put like an oatmeal
cookie in it and I was like I drank like
five of them damn must have missed that
place when I
was okay and where's a date for you
you're a you know a Singlish man I think
running around town by the way the one
night that I saw you it was like a
Friday night you were one of your boys
I'm like what are you guys doing you
going I like we were going to the bakery
I'm like the bakery the bakery a cool
bar you don't know about where was you
were going to Martha's Bakery to get
like cheesecake or something like that
yeah yeah yeah that's true that's true
but Martha's Bakery that's a staple
where I got if boys come to town seeing
Superman getting beat up I was like ah
man I wanted to hear you going on orgy
or something like that I did have a
buddy in town and we went pretty hard in
the paint we drank almost every single
day and he's a big movie guy we go to
movies together so we saw movies and
then we get drunk see movies get drunk
and then one day we were so hung over
that I was like do you want to go out
he's like can we just like play fortnite
and I was like yeah let's do that
immediately turned into a
9-year-old but yeah going on a date
usually I'll take a girl to like uh not
a fancy place but a place that has
something good like oh this spot is
really known for like a really good
burger and you can sit down and have a
drink so you do dinner off rip you don't
you don't do the let's get a drink see
how things personalities match or
whatever sometimes they'll do that but I
feel like food is a good sales point and
also if you want like a girl to be like
Ina it's like I I'll take you I think
girls really like a spot that it's like
it's if I want a girl to be into me I'm
not taking her to watch me eat a burger
I'm tell you much that's that's not
going to seal the deal she's like Jesus
Christ I'm eating hers yeah do you have
a Tide pen on
you going to finish that he what's up I
haven't even started
actually yo but yeah I wanted like a
hole in the wall spot that's cool and
kind of trendy or something like that
that I think is a good place to bring a
chick picking up the check yes always
always I I don't think I've ever not
picked up the check gotcha really
gentlemen yeah no I think that's that's
that's the move and and you just like
you want to be a dude too there's a a
modern man to a certain extent there's a
lot of things I'm modern on but that is
like yeah I'm still a [__] shival us
at the end of the day when I was waiting
tables I would see that so much and it'
be like some Dime Piece I'm like you're
going to [__] this guy are you kidding
me just [__] put down three credit
cards what the [__] is going on exactly
that's [__] they're Independent Women
Hank they also want to pay sure or you I
used to do the dirt bag thing of my wife
would when I was broke my wife would
venmo me money and so I could pay so I
could I could represent I could present
like I'm paying that's so funny that's a
keeper right there oh yeah she knew how
to keep up appearances dude it's like
yeah I'm the man of the house and she's
like yes you are sweetie you're the man
of the house keep with three bucks in
there too I want to get some
gum I want to get my gummy bears
after not a proud man oh yeah oh go I
was jammed up to days were you know they
weren't great back then this when you
were dating oh I would also may be
married no not you dating's worse in the
beginning no we were da we that would
happen if we were all going out there'
be like if we all out and everybody's
like all the dudes were like all right
throwing their credit cards up to chop
up like a 10 person thing or whatever
she'd ship me maybe like two h under the
table D love I got it I got babe put
your card away I got it she it in the
men's room for you behind the toilet you
want a chick like that you want a lady
who's like on board when it's not
good and she was she also funded this
whole thing by the way she's she's
running a puppet
government we call her the foreign
investor she's the one who yeah
literally used all her all her stolen
money from somewhere dude and it paid
off it paid off she P She bet good she
bet good but now she's walking around
asking for you know points on the back
end I'm like hey touch your your loan
was paid back in full all right can you
get me this purse uh I don't know but I
think you've if you've seen our
agreement is sealed and done I'll venmo
you 200 bucks at dinner if you want me
to I get you whatever you want just
venmo me
please pick it up let's get to some cues
boys let's do it gang uh please pleas
thank you oh yeah sorry I apologize okay
that got
weird gang as you know when you sign up
for the old patreon you can have a
question read right on the air mhm
that's
my I that's the same thing we always say
I know okay you're right uh we're gonna
do that right now I swear to God we'll
do it right now [__] weatherman over
here uh yeah so when you sign up for the
patreon you'll get your garbage question
read on the air you didn't do same
thing uh yeah so here we go let's see
this is can your Canadian boy uh so this
is the prince of trash since 1995
Canadian homie here never had one read
anyone else's family leave the important
legal documents in the freezer what
that's I've heard I think I've seen that
in like mob movies or something you
would see I've never done that though no
no no no my dad sent me like uh
basically a whole bunch of [__] that I
became his I can't remember what it's
called but like if he gets sick I take
over exeutive exe power of attorney or
something get switched over I kept that
in my sock drawer that's where that went
yeah they'll never look here they'll
never and I think I lost it too I think
I lost all that paper you got
copies so I hope you nothing
happens I don't know what the [__] to do
yeah I don't think I have any I have a
couple uh for this like there's like a
lease I have in like a binder that I
think is in my closet that's the best I
could do I got no clue where my birth
certificate is I found oh you found it
not too long ago I think there's pizza
sauce on it but yeah yeah that's fine
dude that just means it's
authentic this is original pizza sauce
here yeah it's
him you don't need your ID little taste
test H oh yeah um two things I lost
anytime we had to do that stuff when we
were a kid you like if you had to bring
your social security card or your birth
like little league lose it yeah my mom
would freak out I've lost my birth of
like twice why did they I understand
there was all you needed your birth
certificate like once every 2 years or
whatever who wanted a birth certificate
to play little Le I don't know that's
insane you like whatever like what yeah
that I remember that don't lose it I
swear if you lose it was there a bunch
of kids coming in fake in their ages
like yo this kid's 25 full mustache
dingers yeah Danny tuser I'm 9 years old
it's my wife
Patrice and we're in the third grade
dude see him just shooting up [__]
Tren in the bull pin yeah WRA this up I
could be like work in a half an hour
that in social security guards you
thought they were going to be the most
important thing ever and it's like you
know you never need your M looks like
something from Lord of the Rings you
have to carry you used to be like it's
like a pirates map it's
all you have to hold it up to a light
dude it's nuts throw it in the fire to
see what it really says
yeah the Oracle one fat kid to rule them
all yeah [__] it was trash cuz I had
it in my wallet for a long time for
about 4 years there was a time you had
it yeah that was no but for about 4
years maybe five years ago that was my
main identification I didn't have a
license oh really damn I had I could
drive but I just didn't have a driver's
license yeah yeah yeah yeah you're just
driving without so you got pulled over
and you showed him a social security
card that's okay I wasn't no I wasn't
driving back then the only thing that I
ever got away with that I told you is I
I flew from New York to Atlanta with my
social security card they let you do
that no picture ID yeah holy who else
would be
20299 84 it's me yeah I couldn't believe
they did it this was maybe 5 years ago
and they were probably like oh whatever
this gu This Guy's in bad shape he needs
this he needs this give them the peanuts
put them in a back row give me two meals
and a couple of headphones sell these
when you land dude I would like to see
you pull that off with a turban let's
see if you no not a chance not a
chance K let's talk about that Mando
about popping up everywhere you a smelly
bastard goddamn miracle in modern
science I'll tell you that right now
gang you can start 2024 off hung over
but at least you could do it without
stinking up the joint K puts huh Mando
is an
allbody deodorant big guys you know what
I'm talking about I don't got to use my
lady's Speed Stick under my grundle put
a little Mando on there and the secret
is mandelic acid mhm stops body odor
before it even starts and do yourself a
favor pick some up and quit kicking yeah
you can put it any you can put Mando
anywhere you put in your pit your junk
your feet anywhere you stink and didn't
watch don't put it in your mouth it's
about time somebody develops something
like this cuz it ain't just the armpits
no it's everywhere on you oh man I got
folds I got nooks and crannies you
should be eating this stuff uh guys make
the switch to Mando if you want to if
you want to smell awesome in this new
year I promise you're going to love it
here you go here's the turkey Mando
starter pack is perfect for new
customers it comes with a solid Stick
deodorant cream tube deodorant two free
products of your choice like mini body
wash and deodorant wipes plus res
shipping are you garbage listeners get a
discount code to help you get hooked on
our favorite smelling whole body
deodorant on a market right there new
customers get $5 off a starter pack with
our exclusive code that's 40% off your
starter pack use code garbage at
shop.com shop Mando s h o p m a n d
o.com it's almost a guarantee that once
you get a whiff of your new sack you'll
never go back how you doing that's what
I'm talking about Kip this is Adam and
Eve baby cram it in wo it's a new year
get some new toys the blast off in the
2024 with blast off in your butthole
gang do yourself a favor you know we
love Adam and Eve and we know you love
them too very discreet nice things sent
right to the house to spice up the sex
life we're talk dildos talking butt
plugs and they got a whole section for
50 Shades of Gray you ever see that
movie no I watch thought it was about
your butthole I watched it with my mom
by accident it's about to take a swing
at herba gang do yourself a favor get
over to Adam and Eve they're one of our
absolute favorites and again like I said
we know they're one of your favorites
too have a little fun it's 2024 who
knows how long this thing is going to go
on let's get weird man uh what's the
problem sure the Brand's been around for
over 50 years and this is high quality
[__] we're talking here I ain't asking
you to shove a number to pencil up your
butt I'm talking German engineered leave
the Cucumbers for the salad yeah you can
trust them to give you a good time don't
wait better sex is just a click away
take 50% off one item and free shipping
when you and free Rush processing just
go to Adam andeve.com and select any one
item use the code garbage at checkout
this is an exclusive offer for are you
garbage listeners be sure to use the
code garbage to get your discount 100%
free shipping and Rush processing that's
Adam andeve.com promo code garbage Adam
and eve.com code garbage do it jam it in
but Patty in the 80s and 90s she doesn't
do it anymore cuz we made her stop cuz I
think she lost something when she got a
new refrigerator one time she like left
it in there but she used to have
everything was in there she had jewelry
jewelry things that probably weren't
even worth anything they were just
sentimental value she would have them in
the freezer like under the chicken or
something like that that's wild I've
never heard of this before trash is that
like if you break in no one's going to
check the freeer free oh [__] yeah I I
still keep stuff in
my it's so funny you like hide stuff and
I'm like no one will look here and I'm
like this this is where they would look
it's always in like a top drawer
somewhere so you put it somewhere you
don't forget it but it's also going to
be the first place someone comes and
rips open a drawer and like oh there's
an well it's in the freezer you got to
put a hammer in there so you can smash
and shatter your documents that'd be
real crazy if you're freezing stuff like
your old GI Joe's when you were a kid
yikes I do keep one thing in in my dad's
ear I figur no one's gonna look in there
yeah putting stuff in the ashes yeah not
in the ashes I'm not
buried not a cocka poo what is it uh
it's it's my dad's ring I keep it in
there all right so that's a little
that's not yours though it is mine yeah
but that's also it was I got a fair and
square in The Inheritance I'm saying
you're not putting your extra set of
keys in there or something dude you're
not like it's not that's that's part of
the tribute to your father keep my weed
in there yeah you're not [__] it's
weird you open that thing and it's just
a it's a b it's literally a [__]
plastic bag of Ashes yeah didn't take
him out of the bag you got to un let him
breathing no you don't you don't put it
in there I think so no what do you not
I'm not sticking my hands in that my
goddamn father could be his butt holes
for all I know which part of dad is this
which part did they give you give him
the
[__] here the ear
moaning I think you're supposed to take
it out and just keep it in the ear no no
I have no clue man he not dry cleaning
what are you doing I don't think you
should be out in a plastic bag he's in a
he's not sitting up in a plastic bag
when the show you had a fat sack of dad
that's a heavy bag he eyeballed it he
eyeballed it he didn't have a Digi on
him two keys in my father right there
not stepped on either dude yeah you put
in with the coke to chop it up a bit
we're trying to spread this out a lot
dude you're tasting us good
dad a pocket knife make my face go numb
yeah no you don't touch that you leave
it in in the bag in the Aon I didn't
even think it was going to unscrew but
it did oh [__] I was like he's trying to
out I mean who the [__] would look in
there no one goddamn scumbag plus most
people would have the heebie jeebies
yeah and I think if you're a thief you
have some level of respect I sure I did
talk to a guy rules gent's rules you
don't mess with ashes I talked to a dude
at a show who said that he would Rob
people he did time in prison for a
burglary and he's like oh we would steal
like TVs laptops stuff and he's like we
would steal the remotes just to [__]
with people take all the remotes bastard
what leave a TV and steal the remote
steal the remotes oh I'd [__] freak
out yeah dude we have two now oh just in
case yeah cuz I [__] I can't find it
all the time yeah yeah so there's always
one yeah there's always one floating
around but did you notice now all the
remotes there's no batteries it's all uh
solar solar yeah is that the what the
[__] what do I live in a greenhouse
exactly I got to put that thing by the
window yeah no it should the room light
should do it no mine keeps running out I
got to put it by the window think you're
watching too much TV you pick a channel
and let it let it heal a bit will you
keep it at my dad's earn I love the idea
you just setting it like a plant in the
yeah dud bringing it with water and
stuffy 10 more minutes we can watch our
shows talking to it to give a good vibes
yeah play a little Mozart uh and people
aren't stealing TVs anymore though right
they're too big and they're not enough
money yeah you're not flipping that for
nothing dude like a phone unless like a
crackhead I guess maybe would but like
oh dude when they if you're like a
burglar you're not when they steal the
McDonald's uh TVs ever see that no oh
yeah see you know McDonald's they have
like the menu will be like on a TV
that's all it shows programmed in there
they'll steal one and then they'll
[__] sell it to somebody they'll get
it home and hook it up and [__] it's
only McDonald's just a value value oh
that's so funny dud which I wouldn't
mind having one of those just in The
house's decoration exactly and if it
like updates you're like oh new prices
they got the items they're still updated
Shamrock Shakes back in 20 minutes
that's how you know you're a fat ass if
I have that in there like like a
McDonald's ticker yeah going like old
school Wall Street oh it's back they're
they fixed ice cream Machin the one down
the street let's
go uh all right let's see here this
one's from Dr o zic um ever eat
something for money eat some oh that's a
home run of a question cuz if you have
you're trash and probably a lot of
people have dude I think I I must have I
must have eaten something for money
every crew had a kid when you were a
teenager that would do something for
five bucks yeah yeah I wasn't that kid
but I definitely have like we you know
we make like a [__] mix and you just
like pour a bunch of [__] into a blender
or something I think I've eaten
something like that I can't remember
what the [__] it was though but it was
for sure horrific yeah we had a kid on
Lacrosse bus eat a callus a callus a
callus on the bottom of somebody off the
bottom somebody's foot Jesus Christ yeah
he sliced it off and then he ate it did
he gulp it or chew it chewed it oh no
way dude that's cannibalistic that's
human flesh I think he's dead now to be
honest with for sure either that or he's
a huge callous dude got athletes mouth
we
always tongue won't stop itching bro
there was this story out of [__]
newfinland they was like [__] what
the [__] are you reading Jesus Christ
and here's Chay with the Canadian
report this guy ate two
loonies this dude he got dared he dug up
bodies took the skulls and then made
soup in the skulls yeah ande that's
something
different that's not eating like a Chili
Pepper or something in his defense it
was a double dog aare he couldn't back
down no New Finland that's the one chip
challenge that's what that is
cannibalism holy [__] man get a booger
will
you holy in my early 20s uh my cousin
married a guy who was on the uh who was
in the NFL so we had a lot of cash I was
dead broke so every time we were
drinking I always I was the idiot that
would do anything for 20 bucks it would
be like jump in that Lake I'm like okay
I'll give you 10 bucks I'm like no
problem sir please we we're a wedding
stepping on a rake at a Christmas party
yeah there was a lot of beer CH like you
can't chug that picture in two minutes
or like whatever it was man I'm like you
met the wrong guy let's go you don't
know how poor I am man I get drunk in
cash let's go holy babe I don't need a
venmo this time I got 20 bucks for
eating my own [__]
[__] that was that Philly thing where
the dude ate the horeshit right oh yeah
that was in Philly and that was a that
was a moment of Pride for it was after
the Eagles won the Super Bowl he ate the
the the horse [__] I go for Philly every
year now to win the Super Bowl because I
want to see [__] like that he sent me
there was there was a great video that I
had seen right before you sent it to me
the other day of that old guy at the
Eagles game who gets drunk and then the
girl pushes him and he falls and he
can't get dude I've been that guy he
grabs on the her to try to get up or you
go to pull yourself up and you realize
your motor skills aren't there you're
like all right hold on let me let me
recalibrate for second he starts like
kicking her cuz he can't get up he's
like well I'm not done fighting still
got some fight left in that kind of
happened to me in uh where were we San
Francisco remember I was sitting in that
chair and it broke and I like I like
went down and couldn't narrow it down a
little I couldn't really get up it's a
real you guys had you guys came
Francisco somewhere it it was one of
those chairs that has like the L yeah
there's no there's no back legs it was
Chicago yes and we were getting ready to
record a patreon episode in Chicago and
he sits down and then like this and we
were like oh hey we'll help you I
tightened it up a lot too I was down
like 60 lb at the time the [__] let me
hold on to my
pride dude you're on the ground all
pride is out the door man I was kicking
them yeah it's crazy man like dude that
guy's like 60 yeah dude what the [__]
could have happened where you're [__]
yelling at some woman next to you trying
to fight her you might have had a good
reason I don't know you you just drink
that much you get into it you're a new
person you forget who you are and like
and you're mad about whatever H if
you're drinking that much you're you
know you're probably not in a great
emotional state I mean he was scooching
yeah he was scooching trying to dude get
back I felt so bad for him F dude get
out of here uh a guy in my family went
viral guy in my family he's pushing 90
something and he got in a fight over a
parking spot in aaha and it went viral
like on bar stool he fought like an 80y
old or something and they there was like
four punch five punches thrown none
landed they called the stumble in the
jungle or something he like he like fell
off the curb and then like he tells the
story like yeah he didn't know it went
vir he's like a grandfather and he
didn't know it went viral so we were
like oh what happened he's like yeah I
[__] hit him with a left I hit him
with a right I uppercut it him like you
whiffed three times and broke your hip
dude in his mind it was like the [__]
the lights the people are cheering
everyone's losing it the Wawa gives them
free sandwiches for life so I go back to
making out with this bro it's all over
it was very much that you know he had no
idea there was video footage of it but I
do appreciate a video where an old guy
[__] up a young guy oh yeah yeah that's
great just like with a real like real
solid 607s technique just a just
connects yeah and he's like you don't
know what I've been through man i' SE I
went to Vietnam never saying cool [__]
like the sweet science never
changes I'll give you the one too yeah
always talking weird [__] to
you
man uh that that's all I I get a lot of
videos too of uh a drunk guy or you know
some Street tough guy who comes in is
like I'm 88 and 88 and0 in street fights
and he walks into like a a gym of some
sort either martial arts are boxing and
gets [__] wor and that guy the the
master or the [__] coach or whatever
is always real like all right come on
let's go and then they they then lose it
at some point you want to talk [__] I'm
and they're just [__] like yeah get
them dude did you ever see vice grip
vice grip so there's this uh fight page
called Street beefs I think it's in
Florida and it's all Backyard fighting
in like a c literal like fence cage oh
yes yes yes yes yes that they're n
that's got to illegal oh I think it's
super illegal and it's just dudes who
have like a little training or something
and some guys fight in like suits it's
very strange wild and there's this guy
who went on called vice grip and vice
grip was like I I'm 67 years old I've
trained my whole life I've never fought
I want to see what I got and he fought
and I think he had one win and two
losses but it was very am like he wasn't
like shitty he was just like I want to
see if I got it and I was like [__] yeah
vice grip I like your [__] 67 years old
he might maybe he wasn't that old but he
was old he was old yeah some 25-year-old
and
shirt dudee he beat up one young kid
knocked him out and I was like let's go
[__] as an old guy I if you're
Justified that's got to feel so good oh
yeah going back to the VFW or whatever
tell so good yeah drinks for free on
that guy we had a guy do that but he
looked like an [__] we were at some
party uh in high school and the mom had
just gotten divorced so she like knew
that we kind of hung out in there and
like you know she was like dating and
you know she was younger and all that
stuff so she had like a couple of dudes
with her like her guy she was dating and
then another couple and looking back
they were probably 35 40 at the time but
we were like 16 and these other kids
showed up and we were boys with them but
they just weren't allowed to come into
the house and we were like the mom was
like talking to them outside and like
everything was cool and this guy just
comes running down the [__] driveway
he's like well he said get the [__] out
of here and he grabbed the one kid and
just starts wailing him in the face Jes
but it didn't do anything cuz the guy
was [__] 40 years old yeah he a the
kid took the punch was like nothing like
all right dude what the [__] man yeah oh
we had the opposite of that it was a
graduation party parents had left too
much booze for the kid you know what I
mean like that's when you start drinking
you're 18 sneaking beers in we're all
down we're out on the back deck man and
a fight a scuffle breaks out between us
like it'd be like if me and Foley got
like ah [__] you [__] you and kind of
started pushing each other whatever oh
they were both
crying both lost the fight
Maes we're pinching each other and
this
kid's older significantly older sister's
new
husband it's like we said no fighting
dude he came out and was clearing the
deck like WrestleMania dude he was dude
are getting tossed these [__] clothes
he and we were all were like we all
tried to be like hey man like grab him
and then it was just like not happening
no I'm [__] on the
loose love it it was like that that
video of that dude in like the the vest
with the tie did you ever see that one
fam it's like the the meme is like when
uh when you when I me my brother try to
take my Dad's keys
after you're talking about like Irish
looking guy he's wearing like a mumer
and Son's vest he's beating the [__] out
of those two dudes dude that's what that
dude that dude came in with those vibes
and just cleared House of like 10 18
year olds that's how you want it to go
though you don't wanted to go the other
way where it's like yeah your your
sister's husband and he's an older guy
and then gets beat up by oh [__] you
don't live that down some kid kicks your
ass I always say it man the guys that go
to football games like that like older
guys with their kid and they get into a
fight and get beat up in front of the
kid and you look at the kid's eyes and
you're like scarred for life it's also
probably not the first time that's
happened in front of that and it
definitely won't be the last but you got
to lose a lot of respect and love for
the man for sure getting beat up in a
Barry Sanders jersey Jesus Christ OU
it's got stains on it and [__] come up
there's mustard all over your head beer
and [__] yeah what why you lucky are you
done done he done kicking my ass in
front of my kid things would have been
different if I didn't have this foam
finger man the kids just like no not my
dad my one hero I so want to know the
story behind that guy in the mford and
Son's outfit that's it looked like
waiter fights so they look they look
like had just done a double shift or
something like that he was fighting two
food Runners it's no they're they're in
like boxes they're in fighting gear he's
wearing jeans and he looks like he's
he's de Bart he looks like he's working
a Brun shift somewhere dude and he they
put it in slow motion and he's [__]
he's really whooping too yeah he's like
throwing them well he's like seven feet
tall and those other guys are like 53
what a m that's the matchup you want to
see two little guys versus one huge guy
who can throw a
dud yeah why don't they start doing that
like UFC and stuff like that that would
be awesome that what UFC used to be
there was no weight classes dude there
so it was like a 400lb guy versus a
[__] 100b guy but never two on one no
there was uh two on one would be all
right there was
uh get
on call me he listens Dana big supporter
big supporter he's the man love him well
that's kind of what happened with the
with like the YouTube boxers I'm like
show me a spectacle like show me
somebody actually the oh something crazy
on either side I want I want to see the
circus of it all two Bobcats versus a
guy or something like that you see the
midgets race the camel what yeah there's
this it was an old thing called Man
versus Beast or something it was a TV
show and they had like eight crazy in a
relay race a camel Jesus [__] who won
the camel of course those things can
move it's like a
horse that's nut it was so
great oh God all right let's see here uh
this is from Foley Kudos bar uh is it
trashy to clip your keys to your belt
loop on your pants I've been doing this
for most of my adult life until recently
someone said I look like a janitor Toby
Toby doesn't clip yes he does you clip
your keys Carabiner dude no I got no
Carabiner I used to be a c guy wait a
minute wait a minute used to be 6 months
ago no two years maybe that old Studio
you were for sure for sure now that I
think about it yeah but that was a that
was a while back okay a clip two years
ago I'm like I think it was about a year
and a half yeah but it's been a long
time since I had I had keys clipped to
the clipped to the jeans now why did you
just have so many keys you couldn't put
them in your pocket what what's the
thing I'm incredibly irresponsible CH oh
that how are you losing like they go in
your pocket and they only come out when
you a look thing that's a look cuz a lot
of guys who look like you do that a lot
of barbacks have that [__] they're
running around with a case of [__] a
lot of guys on bike I have my bike
locked on there yeah okay okay that
makes a little more sense that a lot of
guys with ice buckets coming downstairs
jamming me up as I'm trying to get
upstairs sorry man sorry sorry
sorry oh you got to get in the freezer
hold on a second yeah that's uh yeah
that's that that's you want people to
know you're kind of got stuff going on
sure it's a look it's a look it's
practical I'll give you that it's
practical but it's a look or your own
property you're like a janit it's a
janitor mode yeah you got so many doors
to open but I have I have like three I
think I have two keys I no I have three
I have one for the front door one from
my place and then the mail key that
those are all my keys so you're rolling
out just a day three keys three keys
that's it I'm three keys too yeah I
don't got what else I Keys here I have
one for the door but not downstairs cuz
there's too many keys I don't like
having a lot of keys there you go you I
probably got about eight eight eight
Keys holy [__] keep them in no keychain
no nothing just no not lose keys in your
[__] pocket I mean just the hook oh
yeah okay okay yeah yeah yeah I thought
you were talking about you just got
eight Keys Flo around crazy a random I
was constantly fumbling you work in the
Matrix no I have Apartment keys
Apartment keys keys to hear and that's
it yeah okay okay that's not that crazy
yeah C there's a lot of keys to here to
keep stuff on [__] locked up gang you
want to look good for 2024 don't you
look tight tighten it up I tell you how
you do it uh-huh it's not going to the
grocery store taking a bunch of time
making a bunch of stuff meal prep and
all that stuff we're talking Factor
America's number one ready to eat meal
kit it's in 2 minutes they're nutritious
they're
delicious I don't know what else to say
yeah all you got to do is heat them up
for 2 minutes that's it I tried to make
a sweet potato in the oven yesterday
it's still in there this is 2 minutes
you're cooking it's seriously that easy
H all jokes aside we've been huge fans
of factor for a very long time before
they were even sponsor of the podcast
shout out to factor it's a great product
they have over 35 meals of Cho from each
week vegan vegetarian keto options and
more seriously uh it beats eating a 3
old meal prep casserole which I've been
do get out of here with that fresh never
Frozen baby Factory event has awesome
snacks you can take with you and
breakfast smoothies juices to keep you
going all day long so here's the Turk
head over to factor meals.com garbage
and use code garbage 50 to get 50% off 5
that's garbage 5 at Factor meals.com
garbage to get 50% off do it do it the
Carabiner got pretty popular oh yeah for
a while that's people started really
using those oh I for sure started off it
was a f should move without question and
becomes practical on your tight black
jeans you clip it on the back hey it's
yeah it's always it's always to the back
right it's never in the front yeah it's
always on that back half it's always at
like 9:00 I can't I anytime I try to
make a move towards fashion like even if
I put on a collared shirt I'm like you
[__] idiot and I just I can't I how
you think that's a move
towards this guy wants me to wear a
matching socks nuts Who Am I oh I'm not
wearing sweaters yeah oh my Johnny Depp
I would use the uh and I loved them when
they first came out when people worked
in offices and it's on a zip tie oh I
had my when I when working at the law
firm I had that with like my your name
badge on your buzzer you have your
master's degree to get Co and you also
feel like you could kill someone with
that around their neck you feel like one
of those spots they had them in like uh
Mission Impossible or whatever it's like
the they're like titanium rope you could
like hang from them and whatever that's
cool as [__] yeah the the lighter leash
on those things is Pretty Tough my buddy
shout out to R yeah they have those they
clips and then it's like a your lighter
my buddy Ryan shout out to Deli he's a
listener use
that in our 20s dude what I always got
it on
me you'd be outside of a bar and you'd
be like the thing with that is like it's
like someone's like oh you took my ligh
I thought about putting a sticker on a
lighter so I'm like no one will take it
but then I'm also living as a guy that's
like I can't lose a lighter like anybody
that anybody that gives a [__] that much
cuz I'm a bad he's bad with bad lighter
he steals he steals them and then like
months later I'm like that's mine like
he steals them then doesn't use them
loses them finds them again you just
brought one from Circle K you gave to me
yesterday I'm like dude I remember
buying this yeah but if you care that
much it's like who gives a [__] I don't
care about the lighter at all the thing
that jams me up is especially when we're
on the road together we share lighters a
lot of you know it's like who has all
lighter right and when uh so you're
[__] if you're on stage sometimes you
go up on stage with it in your
pocket room I make a conscious just
decision yeah usually to make sure cuz I
know you're going to be coming off
looking for a he come off stage looking
for a heater before we go back on and
I'm like it's like the only lighter in
the building is is
yeah you do feel like a loser when you
have to ask people you don't know if
they have a lighter they don't have a
lighter and they give you I'll go see if
I can find one or oh yeah when you're at
a show they're like they're like oh
we'll do anything we'll make you we want
to make you comfortable like Danny
smokes I'll go ask him he's just stuck
in the freezer we don't know where Danny
is Danny's usually a real doesn't like
giving out his lighter because everybody
steals it at work from Danny yeah God
damn I'm not a smoker so I don't really
have that problem too much every now and
again you got the weed going around Stu
yeah yeah lot of free weed in comedy
dobit yes lot of we were somewhere where
like they gave us an amount of drugs
that was like I'm like we have to fly in
8 hours Toronto dude oh yeah
out to cross
international bro when I did that in a
suitcase full of snacks when I did the
show in Denver they gave me so much
mushrooms a dude gave me like one do you
know what penis envy mushrooms are heard
they're like it was like one gigantic
mushroom and it was like blue and [__]
and I was I just left it all in the
green room I was like you guys can have
it I can't get on a plane with this and
I'm also like when do you think I'm
eating this I'm here for 3 Days every
day we're doing a show work every and
it's like what you think I'm going to
eat this like experimental [__] blue
mushroom football siiz mushroom yeah and
just get [__] like no I never take the
drugs the The Comedy Club staff does
make out with uh a lot of the the drugs
that get given to uh the comics 100 soft
stuff we heroin you know whatever you
get I did get 2cb at a show Once which
is this like uh I might have told you
guys you might have told us yeah it's
like that crazy designer drug right yeah
it's like pink and and it's like almost
fluorescent pink I got that in Miami
they really like it down there I didn't
even try remember you tell me about a
research chemical they call it is that
what it is yeah all right well
apparently like the sound of that a
research chemical I'm not a drug addict
I'm a scientist yeah dude my hypotenuse
says I'm [__] up dude hyp hot hpo
hypothesis H hypotenuse is the long end
of a
triangle damn Kippy how the [__] did you
pull that pagum theorem oh dude holy
[__] my
hypotenuse man all right I do miss a I
do miss a lanyard which we've talked
about before spinning a lanyard around
your finger with the all right all right
real jerk off Vibe but yeah it was all
right pretty good it's like chewing gum
L was that spinning it got some
character God there's nothing better
than a dumb guy trying to sound smart
huh yeah hypot is good I would have
never remembered hypotenuse ever until
you said it and it like it's like a bad
Disney
character everybody run here comes
hypotenuse he's on Research Chemicals
the only the only reason I remember that
word is cu I had a math teacher who was
so clearly a stoner and he's like you
can remember hypotenuse by I'm high and
I have pot in use and that was it Jesus
did that guy
red hit you with a wink yeah yo if you
guys need anything meet me behind the
cubicle I hated all that [__] math
[__] sucked yeah it does suck dude
geometry Algebra I algebra like what the
[__] is this guy talking about and you
don't use it they teach all this [__] I
I get that you should it does show that
you can learn and you can understand
bigger Concepts and stuff like I get
that but it's like but then they changed
it like 10 years ago oh the new math I
don't what the [__] is that I see videos
of it and I'm like I have no idea
dumbest [__] I ever heard n they're just
like it's like man kids learn the basic
[__] like [__] taxes how to make
money and like [__] balance a
checkbook there you go yeah that's it
something those are those are what you
need Gary ve High School yeah exactly it
really should be dude I would have
rather gone to that what were the three
things making money uh making money how
to pay your taxes maybe like get [__]
those are your things that's an elective
obviously you don't have to take that
one but it might become it might become
useful you never we had to take an
accounting class and I was [__] lost
yeah [__] that debits and credits and
all this [__] no you guys probably have
a guy like a guy who just handles your
money and [__] who like [__] you're
looking at
him and I failed counting Mr hypotenuse
over
here he's a little obtuse if you know
what I mean nothing on that talk about
we're we like to keep everything in
house yeah dude yeah it was like we're
paying some of the Taxas some not a lot
of write offs
here all for business expenses I needed
that water slide at my house kill us man
the taxes are [__] man I paid my
first round of real taxes last year and
I was like Jesus Christ I I want to go
like can't I go back to a paycheck like
when I used to I remember used to get
$1,500 back every year it stings at
first but then you're like all right I
don't got to worry about that yeah true
it's wild yeah huh [__] brutal um all
right let's see this one's from gravy
boat captain shout out to you uh you
know your Habachi stats I never met a
shrimp I couldn't catch are you are you
a Habachi guy never been to Habachi yeah
yeah no no I think Habachi is I don't I
think we have maybe like one in Toronto
or something like that it's not big in
Canada so I've never ever been to a
Habachi but I would like to take on a
Habachi to go for the whole experience I
want to see the stuff shoot out of the
the the whatever the it's a fun time I
couldn't do it with other people that it
always turned me off yeah yeah the
community table's tough cuz you're just
there with like somebody celebrating a
birthday someone on a wedding like a 10
unless you go with a crew yeah yeah and
buy the whole table all eight of us are
going or whatever that's got to be
that's one of those jobs where I think
like when I weit at tables and I would
go in half speed so many times hung over
[__] up whatever having to do that
[__] and put on a show when you're
cooking dinner it's like [__] off dude
dude the volcano and see them going
through the motions I I'd be phoning in
after the first week they do it and
chefs are very much like we're in the
kitchen we're doing our own thing and Sh
like the environment in kitchen usually
toxic as [__] the rude nasty drug use
sexual harassment out the Wazoo like
they're going nuts in there and then you
got to be a human being in front of
people no that I would do they should
that do that bring that out dude
someone's working at Double they're all
amped up on meth or something like that
they're screaming at each other back
there they're losing tickets the
waitress is bringing things back that
they [__] up on he's screaming at her
d d d that's what you want to see there
we go you do that and then you go to the
kangaroo fights or whatever it is the
kangaroo
fights holy [__] three encants versus
Mongoose I like that I never opted to
catch the I don't I didn't like being I
feel like you're just they're making you
the butt of the joke a fat it's like I'm
not I'm not [__] dancing for scrimps
okay yeah [__] put it on a plate and
give me a fork cuz I don't have much job
spin the egg will you [__] hurry up I
eat like a grown man I'm a grown man
never I've mentioned that before I went
to uh my wife picked a steakhouse and
end up being Salt Bay yeah that dude and
they come out and he tried I mean he was
trying to [__] my wife for sure dude he
was dangling meat like on her Li I was
like yo not that I will beat the [__]
out of you right now there's been a few
videos of dudes salt bit comes to do the
thing so it's so erotic it's insane it's
so crazy and he started doing to me I'm
like I'm I'm good I'm not doing this I'm
not [__] I've told you I've told you
guys this before but there's uh there's
some desert place somewhere I can't
remember if it's in France or somewhere
like that I think it's in Europe um and
it's like a frozen banana place and they
take the banana and they dip it in
chocolate and they put all stuff but the
guy he's like this goodlooking Latin
dude and he like like you know he'll
like hold it and like put it in the
girl's mouth and they're basically like
blowing the thing dude it's so funny he
gets up on the thing and he's like
humping in him and stuff like that and
they're like yeah give me the banana
more
banana let's go yeah I'll sit I'll get
front row seats for that yeah see this
guy hump produce into chicks faces love
it that was a lot of comedy clubs used
to do you remember that the [__] sh
yeah I like what where you working that
was my closer where you working and who
books that I a got to get over there
yeah the old chick who works at the
comedy club who like smoke cigarettes
inside she's like who wants a banana who
wants a banana I've done probably over a
100 [__] shots cuz the it was big at
the laugh house so you had to before the
headliner came up for the head they
would find out whose birthday it was and
then after the feature you do the
announcements this one's coming up that
one's coming up and I heard we got a
birthday in the ground it's always
me third time this month huh crazy and
it's like a shot of Kala and Bailey and
then they put whipped cream on it and
they have to put their hands behind
their back and and get it off the stool
yeah yeah yeah yeah but that rules it's
a tasty shot man it's a good way to get
drunk yeah it's good yeah yeah I love a
Bailey's a Bailey is all right Bailey
White Russian I'm about a White Russian
dude that I don't know if I've ever
really had a White Russian yeah they
they go man it's like you can't drink
too many of them because you'll [__]
[__] your brains out but but they're
they run they run we had to ban bailees
in my house cuz my mom would crack the
bottle and would not stop till it was
gone sure it's good your mom's a good
time man yeah anyone want a special
coffee special coffee a special
coffee Mama's juice
juice shout out to her I like it that's
great we were in college I remember
there was this this a a a frat would do
$5 for the like keg whatever you know
for cups and then they had a little bar
and they would sell shots and I I I
would need like a hundred beers because
it was like you know super shitty light
beer I'm like can I just stand in a
corner [__] slugging beer so they
would have shots feeling real awkward
and we would do shots and yeah just out
out of pure social anxiety as well like
a fat guy at a keep your hands in your
pockets for so
long you can only go you can only look
for the bathroom and I'm going to go
smoke a s so many times before you're
not even at the party you know what I
mean I was out take a lap around the
house see if anybody's out but they had
a bar and they would only sell uh sex on
the beach and fuzzy naval shots yeah so
like ordering those as like a [__] 20
you know n not 20 a 18-year-old kid be
like can I get three fuzzy naval please
and you're just [__] cring them smash
them back oh worst hang over your
[__] it was orange juice and
something else yeah you're going to puke
the rainbow
afterwards dude yeah you want to get
drunk on that that's not your booze of
choice I hated the shooter craze of the
mid 2000s does they have that up in
Canada shooter girls going around the
little vials oh yes yeah yeah and they
put you put in your mouth and just
[__] shoot your head back they put it
between their tits or something like
that yeah I hope they're all CEOs cuz
they were were salesman cuz if you
didn't buy they made you feel like a
[__] loser oh dude I H H I knew this
girl who worked as like a bottle girl
and she said the easiest sell of all
time was to like dudes who have some
girls like they're in the they buy the
table they're trying to impress them so
you go in they buy a bottle or whatever
and then you come back after the
bottle's done you go like oh you guys
want another bottle and they're always
like no no no and you go ladies and
they're like yeah sold sold every
[__] time sold respect the hustle you
could be a bottle girl the only 2000s
you had to clean they were all making
cash yeah dude yeah you got paid back in
sexual harassment for sure that was
definitely part of the job yeah I didn't
make it past the first
interview that was out he wore his best
bra
too I had one buddy fall in love with
one of those shooter girls oh at
Keenan's in North Wildwood man he was
following her around that bar like a
goddamn puppy dog smitten he's like I
think she likes me they really were like
dude you you paid put put her through
college already tonight dude and you
offered her Coke eight
times God damn yeah you can't like
servers bartenders strippers bottle
girls nurses none of them like you none
of them like you man no that was never
maybe don't say none of them don't take
the Hope away from me man I was I was
down at uh a bar in my hometown recently
and like just there was like the hsh
girl you know she's probably like 3 w at
this point she was probably been there
for 10 years and she was always the hot
bar she's a little older and just this
gaggle of like around the around the
corner of the bar like seven dudes all
like look at her huh hey I'll do one
more like all just Loosely hitting on
her and you're like man none of you
stand a chance and you're all tipping
her 200% probably paying her mortgage
yeah dude it's it's wild man like I I I
bartend didn't work this bar for a
little while and the girls that work
there were these like hot French
Canadian chicks tattoos all that kind of
stuff and the guys that would come in
and be like you want to come home with
me like dudes in like their 50s are like
old s and I'm like did you what did you
think was going to happen here this like
hot dude I'm [__]
her but you think you're going to like
you thought you were going to pull like
she could [__] anybody and you think
she's pulling out of this place you know
what I mean sometimes it happens love
happens magic happens sometimes two
people they meet each other and the
Stars line up spoken like a real
sucker
I mean dude that's the next Disney movie
old dude goes to a bar hot chick there
and and they fall in love man just him
picking up her kid from
school your mom at a date I'm I'm
thinking
you but then also too like that
bartender's boyfriend would come in
sometime I spent a lot of time at those
neighborhood bars and like that guy
always sucked he always stunk he was all
but then he was also a dirt bag but just
from like another town or whatever so
you're like there is a chance he this
guy is just this guy at another bar
there you know but damn yeah nothing
worse than the the boyfriend that
waiting tables the boyfriend that hung
out yeah just waiting just waiting I'm
waiting for Sher yeah never start
chiming
in uh all right let's see here this
one's from Bryce $10 homie here when you
lose a sock do you just match it with a
different sock or do you hold on to it
or throw it out oo I definitely hold on
to it because oh yeah I hold on to it
gra period yeah and like I the other
socks probably gone but I buy a lot of
the same socks I've started doing this
too so like another one will appear at
some point or I'll lose another the same
batch and you have that and I got no
problem mixing matching I got no problem
with that I'll throw in a long guy and a
short guy I don't give a [__] holy [__]
that's crazy heard him he doesn't care
about fashion I have trouble when one's
thinner than the other I can't I feel
like I'm wearing two different shoes I
feel like I'm walking
sideways I how much that
kills me I can't do thin socks anyway
cuz my feet like sweat and they get like
weird I need I need a little thickness
absorption but I'm all I'm all good
fella ankle socks oh good I love I got
them on right now yeah and if something
gets mixed in it I dude it just it's not
worth it cuz it just [__] ruins it
because you're missing one you don't
know where this one is it's a [__]
nightmare I got a weird batch of socks
right now cuz I have a bunch of those
good fella guys I like the the ones
you're you're picking up over there but
then I got a bunch from Canada as well
so I have these a bunch of thick like
thick wool socks and sometimes I'm like
yo I only got one of these woolies and
one ankle guy we're going really yeah
I'm in a rush that's nuts winter socks
back in the day they were like almost
like that sweater material they were
like wool wool socks so good Jesus
Christ I I like how it's like wearing
bees on your feet [__] brutal they
get wet that [__] starts itching
I hate that [__] bees on here eat the
most common thing stinging and
scratching at you oh man oh I like a
good comfy sock put on a thick sock and
it goes into a big boot and then you put
on your big coat and you go out in the
cold and just stretch through couple
shots of Fireball to keep you warm yeah
all right now we're talking my language
you lead with that really snuck that in
there did you I don't care what socka we
I didn't know we were doing
shots holy uh yeah okay let's see here
we got time for uh another two more here
this is from Alania uh $5 never have one
R do you cut the price tag off or do you
just rip it off is ripping it off
considered garbage I rip rip I'm a
ripper or a biter oh get the teeth in
there I've I've chipped the tooth on a
40 in high school and it's still it's
got like a little bit of an edge to it
and if I get the plastic thing right
there slices right through it let's talk
about this 40 though will you open them
with your teeth no I was uh drinkinking
a 40 and uh my friend uh biggie rest in
peace bumped into me and it chipped my
tooth very unromantic a fatter guy
bumped into me in the basement you have
a Swiss Army tooth that's fu yeah and
then yeah 240s both teeth have like a
little little smidge on it I'm I'm a big
Ripper uh they've definitely caught on
with that that most people rip a lot of
times they put it on its own thing sure
that's F when when they put it on like a
cloth Loop that's where they [__] you up
oh yeah yeah but I feel like they make
those things almost like breakway now
where it's just literally a little bit
of pressure and they pop the cloth Loop
I'll start just pulling at that thing
thinking I'm going to snap it and it's
like never your shirt the ones who
[__] do it like [__] are the
sock people they have 19 of those in
there yeah it's like get over it dude
and you forget that thing is in there
and I feel like it's in every one of
them you're like I only broke this in
one place how is it in every sock dude
finding it for [__] months put in a
bag will you dude that's it yeah yeah
just throw them my [__] in a in like one
tub and I'll leave here like a like a
human yes yes I'm I'm living off of uh
good fellow socks right now at the
moment same thing you [__] brand new
pack and they're you go you guys go for
the good fellow shirts too I don't fit
them I do the undies I don't like the
way they wash I do the undies and the
socks I don't like way the the te's wash
they so they have they have like the
regular black ones are a certain type of
material where if you wash them they're
wrinkly forever that's what I'm but if
there's other ones like gray and [__]
that have a different kind colored ones
I have I have 20 of them colored I love
those they never wrinkle bro I'm all
about good fell shirts a good brand man
it really is they have like the pocket
or whatever yes they they have a bunch
Target house brand right somebody said
they used to be mosimo mosimo what's
mosimo mosimo used to be like a skater
brand way back in the day I could be
wrong on that tone can you get eyes on
that good fellow masimo I will it sounds
like an Anime Studio you don't remember
masimo I'm surprise MIM was huge in the
9s huge if you had a that it was like a
very stucy type thing wait how do you
how do you spell it uh mosimo there was
like Vulcan and a couple other ones that
were it was like one of the uh it was m
o I got it m m o s oh was I EO
oo um mimo yeah I mean well masimo still
seems to be banging in Australia there
you go all right they found their Market
I like it I like it I don't think it is
cuz nothing comes up with MIM Mo fellas
no no they're they're riding skateboards
out there still they're all over the
streets good Fells is a [__] yeah dude
it's just like you get I buy a pack of
shirts I'll get [__] 10 shirts at
once or whatever and then be like there
I'm good I'll just 20 bucks too yeah
[__] yeah dude and the socks last man
they really do and they get better with
age the underwear is great underwear is
great they they just switched up the fat
guy underwear where it used to be more
Euro cut and now they go they go up real
high yeah and they got the sandwich
Pockets natural bacon scent too yeah you
put in there stays warm stays warm for a
long time
keep my egg bites in
there testicles are
huge all right we got to wrap it up gang
gang we love you to death Chay Dana
going to be at the Wilbur Theater in
Boston January 12th do yourself a favor
few tickets left scoop them up he's one
of the absolute best and he's going to
be over there in Vancouver British
Columbia at the Vogue Theater February
24th my birthday go see the hometown kid
Cher in
everybody thank you love having you pal
yeah' good hang anything else you want
to plug socials anything else website
and you can find it all my socials chera
c h e d r e n a check out the YouTube
we're posting all the standup stuff over
there and then for all tour dates go to
cher.com I'll be probably coming to your
city very soon you're killing it buddy
we're so happy for you best great hang
great comedian we love you all right on
kiy what do you got for him uh we're
taking a bit of a break of the road
we're planning the uh spring and summer
tour right now we have a lot of the
dates uh be posting soon finalizing some
stuff the only thing that's on sale
right now is May May 9th at the Dr Town
Hall Theater New York City it's the
biggest show we've ever done grab the
squad and come out and see us in a nice
nice classy style yes place is nice the
card game available at Ru garbage.com
doing gang we love you and we'll see you
next week peace